Congratulations to Basirudi Omaha Fey,
who is set to become one of Africa's youngest presidents
at the age of 44.
Fey's victory signals a potential shift in Senegal,
echoing a broader trend across Africa,
where younger leaders are assuming positions of power.
This resonates deeply
in a continent with a disproportionately young population,
highlighting the importance of representation
and the potential for transformative change.
We hope he keeps his promise to govern with humility and transparency
and to fight corruption at all levels,
devoting himself fully to rebuilding the country's institutions.
Congratulations to the people of Senegal.
Your future looks promising.
If Senegal succeeds, West Africa succeeds,
an entire continent prosperous.